your style and methodology of dhava
which is very effective. How do you
prepare for dhava or what is your style
of research? Because whenever you answer
something or present something you very
nicely topple down opponent's claim with
very beautiful and unique hikma.
For instance, if someone speaks on
Islamic terrorism, then you counterargue
with some informative things that
ultimately destroys that claim. Please
tell me how you gather such information
and how you structure it and how you
prepare and what is your homework.
Please sir, tell me your routine and
what things
you take for research and how do you do
research? Your dawa affected me so much.
Alhamdulillah. Please help me with some
bit of information or some tricks,
notes, etc. If this message really
reaches you, then please give me
feedback. May Allah protect you and give
ma amen.
The brother Araf Khan has been watching
my videos and he appreciates the way I
do dawa and he says he likes the way how
I use mahikma and I reply to the
opponent and I talk over or rather I
would say as any because Allah says in
the Quran in surah fusil chapter number
41 verse number 34 that
you should win over your enemies.
winning over your enemies is more
important than defeating them really as
far as a question that how do I do my
research and how do I give the reply and
it has been described normally if I'm
supposed to give a talk on women's
rights in Islam I see to it that I read
all the verses in the Quran dealing with
women then I try and correct various
hadith deal with women so that whatever
question that can come on
Inshallah you should be able to answer.
So
the preparation is very important when
you're giving a lecture
the lecture that you give should be
hardly 10 to 20%. You should have five
times more knowledge than lecture you
have given so that you can handle the
question answer. Question answer is more
important for a person you can know how
much is in water. And regarding doing
the course, the best advice I can give
you is that you can watch the course
let's become effective dive
international ding program. It's present
on the al and if you go on the ala
platform you'll find hundreds of courses
and some of them are on compared
religion on dawa and this will tell you
detail how you should research how you
should present yourself and how can you
win over your enemies. Hondan survey.